THAT IS SOMETHING WE ARE
LEARNING AND IT MAY BE LOWER
THAN PEOPLE THINK BECAUSE OF
WHAT I’VE BEEN SAYING.
>> WORKING ON THIS BILL WITH
CONGRESS TO MEET SOME OF THE
DEMANDS THE DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE?
>> President Trump: WE HAD A
DEAL LAST NIGHT AND THE
DEMOCRATS CHANGE THE DEAL.
WE HAD A DEAL LAST NIGHT I WAS
GOING TO BE PHENOMENAL FOR THE
WORKERS WHICH IS MY NUMBER ONE
AIM, WANT TO TAKE CARE OF THE
WORKERS BUT I WAS PRETTY SURE WE
HAD A DEAL LAST NIGHT.
YOU WOULD’VE TOLD ME AT A
CERTAIN TIME ABOUT 9:00, IT
WOULD HAVE TOLD YOU WE PRETTY
MUCH HAVE THE DEAL.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN IT CHANGED
FAIRLY RAPIDLY AND IT WAS
UNACCEPTABLE, WOULD’VE BEEN BAD
FOR OUR COUNTRY AND THEY WERE
ASKING FOR THINGS, THINGS THAT
BORE NO RELATIONSHIP TO WHAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT, THAT’S NOT
THE GAME AND WE CAN’T PLAY THAT
GAME.
THE DEMOCRATS DO WANT TO MAKE A
DEAL BUT I THOUGHT WE HAD A DEAL
LAST NIGHT.
>> AS YOU GO FURTHER INTO THIS
PROCESS, AND DECIDE FURTHER
STIMULUS IS NEEDED, WILL YOU BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH SPEAKER PELOSI
ON THAT?
>> President Trump: I WORK
WITH ANYBODY, I DON’T CARE WHO
IT IS.